hi everyone it's a pleasure to be here
to do a talk on causal inference and I
like to keep things quite basic
so I'm not gonna be talking I don't
assume any knowledge of stats at all
it's gonna be very visual so I'll be
showing you some diagrams and that'd be
like the key part of this talk so the
agenda for today is split into four
parts
but the the biggest part is about the
causal diagram that third public point
so this is a primer on causal inference
essentially what is causal inference
why why why should we care about it and
how do we go about doing a causal
inference and then the bit at the end is
going to be like a wrap up just going
through the types of biases that affect
causal models that we touched upon in
the calls of diagram apart but it's just
going to be like a high-level summary at
the end of the different concepts in
causal inference and so about me I have
my interest in causal inference came
about with my studies in economics and I
took modules in econometrics so using
mathematics and stats to basically
linear models to estimate causal effect
mainly as a public policy questions
economic models and then the last few
years I've moved into data science I
feel it's quite a lot of overlap there
because you have this knowledge of
linear models and then pick up some
machine learning you do analysis science
data for econometrics and then like
picking up Python and icons data science
workflow you can augment that from there
and I've been applying causal inference
methods of trip tease so it's a travel
tech startup in London we sell our
products direct to hotels our product
sit on hotel websites and the main thing
we try to do is help them to compete
with online travel agents like
booking.com Expedia by increasing
the number of guests that book through
the direct channel as opposed to say an
agency so our products are really about
trying to improve conversion rate for
hotels improve the guest experience on
hotel websites and also help them to
acquire new traffic which is what we're
doing with our latest product and then
I've done a little site project recently
called apple pie it's a site that I've
been doing where I made a package to do
do something a bit more than stats
models librarian Python so model
Diagnostics whether as a goodness of fit
in a linear model and even like dummy
encoders that kind of thing just to
improve my workflow so let's begin why
do we care about causal inference so the
main thing for me is that cause of
questions are ubiquitous across many
different fields of applied stats and on
the next slide I'll go into an example
from today which so types of fields are
things like Social Sciences economics
political science
epidemiology Public Health and then the
main thing that I see day-to-day working
in the startup is well people in c-suite
executives who want actionable insights
the kind of questions they might ask are
more about if I do this what what's the
effect well they might be trying to
validate an idea that they want you to
do and you can estimate it later on it's
quite a common thing and so these are
three examples from from those fields so
one thing might be how does passive
smoking affect the mortality of
non-smokers quite a big public policy
issue the last 10 20 years a smoking
bans what is the effect of minimum wage
laws on employment another big thing in
econometrics 20 30 years ago and then
stuff you might see day to day in in
software what the causes of customer
churn at a software company and if you
think about those questions there's a
slight problem here
so of course the inference the means to
go to people have is whether the gold
standard is a randomized controlled
experiment and these three questions is
that something that we can do
unfortunately not so where do we go from
here and this is where we go on to this
next part the ladder of causation this
this framework was developed by Judea
pearl computer science background
professor he started doing this type of
work in the 90s I was touch upon it very
briefly here but if you want to see to
read more about it in a lot more detail
then have a look at his book The Book of
Y that came out a few years ago and he
did a book 20 years ago as well on
causality so that was something that I
up after I'd had this knowledge in
econometrics there are some questions
that weren't quite fitting in the work I
was doing a big data so leaded causation
we have say three different tiers of
looking at questions involve stats so
right on the bottom rung there you have
Association and in principle that's say
how do head as a variable x1 correlate
with your target variable Y and yeah
that's really in the realms of
correlation and very basic descriptive
stats and then right in the middle here
which is we're going to be today is the
intervention part so we have this X 1
but what we want to answer the question
of is what happens to Y when I do x1 so
this is moving from the language of say
what if I do this as opposed to how are
things associated and the counterfactual
part is like even higher level thinking
like what if I done this instead that's
yeah really know much about that and
then we probably some more developments
on that in the future so in the news
today some of you might have noticed
this this article and a few papers it
was about
premature births and the relationship
between that and social later
developments in social life like the
chance of becoming a parent that kind of
thing and this is addiction to the slide
today wasn't the train of thought oh
they're talking about this association
but no one was saying this explains this
I thought this is this is strange
so on the left hand side there's the
paper right there and right over there
it says association so already it's
talking about the language of the bottom
rung of the ladder of causation
association between the variable X and a
target Y but in the press release it
gets a bit more interesting these very
smart authors will be talking about
obviously correlation is not causation
that's something that's kind of been
embedded in stats of the 20th century
and not really moved that far from there
but in in the press release one of these
authors said something like they're
people that born prematurely they have
difficulties and social interaction
interaction at a young age and that
makes it harder for them to do the
social transitions like becoming a
parent and that phrase make it harder
that is like a subconscious language of
causation probably this is something
that they you might even be aware of so
we have to be quite careful when we're
thinking about the questions were trying
to answer and how we frame things so
let's crack on the causal diagram and
with this we're going to be mapping out
the different variables for something
that I'm working on day to day Tripti so
our product there is say our messaging
product few other ones and we were
trying to work out what are the direct
effects of those those things on
conversion rate let's proceed
so this
having a knight in the tower but if you
look at these two images we'll see but
well this they said this is what the
hotel looks like and then her down here
this is what you might see might have
seen a few days ago if you're booking a
hotel room on Google so just a raise of
hands how many of you is staying in this
hotel tonight there might be a few of
you yeah so about 20 percent of people
and then keep those hands up if you
booked the hotel room online it's very
similar to before so majority of you
staying here tonight would have would
have booked online and that's one of the
main developments in travel tech of the
last well ten twenty years really people
moving away from say high street agents
to online travel agents and hotel
websites and so so let's think about
when you might been booking that room
you might just typed in Tower Hotel
London on Google and you might think
where is just so much stuff going on
here you've got all these adverts at the
top from hotel Expedia booking calm and
then on the side there you've also got
the same thing
booking calm hotels calm is adverts on
the side panel and if we just zoom in to
something we're on the hotel website and
on here there are two different just
just on that page there are two
different ways of getting to the hotel
website so the first one on the Left
that's organic search so if you click on
there it will take you through to the
hotel website homepage but this one on
the right
Google has this panel here that has like
a default search and if you click on the
hotels advert where it says official
website click on that and it will take
you through later in in the in the
booking journey it will take you through
to something called the booking engine
and that takes you that one step closer
to to booking a room and
for us the trip tees its product
development we're just thinking a lot
about our different products and
different things in the market so even
say the pricing for example how does
that affect people's likelihood to book
and how can we improve
the guest journey on on hotel websites
so super down to basics this this is
like an illustrative hotel website
funnel and as you go down this is
something that applies across a lot of
e-commerce right so the top you might
have say a hundred people visiting the
hotel website and as very typical in
e-commerce most of those people will
bounce and what that means is where
you'd have just clicked on on the page
and they'd have done nothing on the
website at all they'd have just I don't
know gone to drink some tea gone outside
been distracted by something and then of
those people that haven't bounced
there'll be people that have done the
search
they've got okay and rate a poker room
let me find the price and all that kind
of stuff and so you might have 20 people
out of a hundred who who do a search but
even then there's quite a big drop-off
in the number of people who make a hotel
booking and for that it it might just be
too so the conversion rate of people who
have done a search 2/20 of 10 percent
and suddenly having a lot of issues in
machine learning of stuff like imbalance
data and in causal questions to you will
have a lot of null data so there'll be
people that have not done a search or
people that have bounced and you have no
not really much information at all about
them and you can't reuse that for
modeling that much so it's an
interesting thing thing to model so what
are the different factors that could
affect conversion rate on on hotel
websites so there are the things such as
seasonality
people are more like to book a certain
time of the day or
day of the week even some periods of the
years such as Black Friday in November
that's quite a big thing the last few
years for hotels to shift some of their
inventory things like traffic source so
as we saw earlier you have organic
search on Google on the left and then on
the right you have the displayed
advertising and one thing we notice is
the people who click on ads and may be
more likely to convert then you have
things like device people would like to
convert on on desktop the mobile that's
a very common thing in e-commerce and
even something especially for the hotel
sector is is pricing so online travel
agents many years ago they would often
undercut hotels so in on the Google
space there you might see the hotel
website is 10 percent more expensive and
as a consumer you might think well this
is the same same item but it's cheaper
through the OTA the online travel agent
and that is a big thing that affected
hotels and one of our products has
helped to to shift that power a rate
away from OTAs and empower hotels to to
achieve this thing called rate parity
where they they can ensure that their
prices are the same as online travel
agents and there's no like difference in
pricing that would entice them away from
the hotel website so in terms of
products let's consider two two theories
that people might be having in like a
whiteboarding session in the office so
it could be well I think that
personalized messages on hotel websites
have a positive effect on conversion
right and someone else might also say
well searches from Google on just the
google.com page have a high likelihood
of convert of booking a hotel room and
that also leads us onto the issues of
experimentation we'll find that one of
those we can experiment quite easily the
other one it's not the case and this is
an example of what our messages look
like on hotel website so the
personalized message might be if you've
been looking for a room to stay
somewhere
in five days time you might be displayed
a message like this last minute break
this is a discount that we can offer you
that kind of thing or complimentary
items so in terms of experimentation can
we can we assign well this this concept
of treatment so if you're trying to vary
a variable if you're trying to go
through different values of a variable
say like a binary one yes or no if I get
someone to do this if someone does this
can you can you randomize it okay can it
be a nice experiment with personalized
messages tryptase yes that is something
that can be done and we do that a lot
with our hotels so we have over 10,000
hotels as kind so we have the scale of
data to do stuff like a bee testing but
the searches from Google point that's
something we can't randomize and if
you're interesting the causal effect
we'd need something like the causal
diagram to help us estimate that direct
effect so this this is I guess the
halfway point and it's quite a chunky
slide to explain so this this is the
first iteration of the cause of diagram
so here we want to map out all the
domain knowledge we have about a problem
about space so let's let's say we want
to to model the direct effect of on-site
messaging on conversion rate conversion
behavior so the one that's not labeled
there why if we treat that as a target
variable and that that's someone that's
converted or not yes/no and then the
direct effect of messaging which is the
box M is the white arrow between M and Y
and this is something we have reason to
believe is a positive effect from the
data analysis we've done many times
before so with the causal diagram you
can map out all the different variables
in involving a problem and map out the
the direct relationships between these
variables so you might have done some
exploratory data analysis you might have
okay I've got all these variables in my
data set with millions of rows what are
the correlations between m and y G&Y
you might find that they go against what
what you think the causal effect would
be and that is because there is this
interaction in this in this space
between variables that can bias
estimates of causal effects so I'll just
walk through quickly the these paths one
by one the arrows so the first one if we
if we start at the top someone that
comes from Google from the data we've
seen before we think they're more likely
to to convert there later in in the
booking journey we have reason to
believe that there is this positive
arrow this positive association between
those two variables was not an
association it's a direct effect and
then the other the other one from google
sauce so we saw earlier that people that
click through from google go straight to
the booking engine that means that as
soon as they've landed there they have
done a search whereas people that would
have gone from another source channel
they might not have brought they would
have done a search necessarily because
in my bounce so with that we think
there's it's positive effect on people
coming from google on search search
patterns and then going from search to
it's a conversion
it's a convert on hotel website you need
to have done a search it's not really
quite the stage where you can get google
assistant to do the booking for you but
we can think that would be quite strong
quite a strong effect and that other
implications for modeling the direct
effect of M or Y and then the other two
so people that have done a message and
then going towards a search people that
see a message that that button in the
middle that says book now
if you click on that that will take them
straight to the booking engine and don't
we see with these decent click-through
rates people who seen a message are more
likely to make a search and the final
one for the products we're doing the
direct effect we really want to estimate
we believe that an on-site message will
make someone more likely to convert and
this this diagram space itself there are
different ways you can name it so one
thing that it's called in literature is
Bayesian network and as a structure as
well it's it's a directed acyclic graph
a dag so you don't have cases where
between two variables you have arrows
going in both directions that can happen
sometimes it happens in econometrics or
stuff growth modeling price and quantity
and then demand and supply modeling and
that needs special linear models to do
that kind of stuff and then yes so going
will have having this space in mind as
an initial start how do we go about
estimating this direct effect the white
line or the white arrow we need to
consider different ways of going from M
to Y as that can bias estimation so for
any given diagram if you met everything
out the temptation might be
oh and a linear model I'll add all the
variables I have in a data set into the
model and just run it more more more and
features will be useful for me but
that's not the case sometimes because
that like depending on the interactions
between variables that can bias your
estimates of that direct effect so the
one thing we want to look for is these
things called backdoor paths so these
are ways to get from M to Y through
these orange arrows and in this case
I'll walk you through these there are
two different backdoor paths and let's
say we start with a model a linear
linear regression modeling why just with
M as the very basic model and then we
need to think
of these different variables how do we
add other variables in to give us a
valid estimate and so of that you might
think okay I can control for G or s or
another variable so yeah there - there -
backdoor pulse in here so the first one
is you can go from n so as to why and
then m2 s - G - why those are the two
paths that we want to block and the can
you go from s to G m2 s to G - y-yeah so
one thing that might seem a bit
confusing is you don't have to worry at
the moment about the arrows and the
direction they go it's if you think of
it it's like a flow of the liquid or
something like water and it's you can
find your ways if you push hard enough
kind of thing that's like one metaphor I
might give so there are lots of things
that will make most paths are are not
blocked they're open and we need to
control for a variable to block that
path the one case where a variable we
don't need to control for something on a
backdoor path is if you have this
variable being a Collider and I'll go on
that this towards the end in more depth
but if you have inside a pot so if I
just do for this one examples that m2 as
to why that's not Collider we can block
that path with s so we can control for s
s is actually a confounding variable
because as a direct effect on Y and it's
related to to M what we care about that
the effect of a message so in this case
a Qaeda would be the case where M goes
to s but Y goes to s so that s to Y
arrow goes in the opposite direction so
you have these three variables and then
right in the middle we have s and the
other two variables collide into it
if that were the case we wouldn't need
to control for that variable but as
we'll see in this next path s is now a
Collider we have m2 s G Y and in here we
now have s two variables M mg directly
going into it that's now a Collider and
we said before that if you if well if
you block if you if you control for a
Collider variable that will introduce
bias into the model so it's not
something that you want to do and so the
counting for this the fact we have to
control for it from the previous path we
now have to find somewhere else in that
power that will enable us to block block
it again
so here the next part is G G can block
this path so we can control for that in
the model this is quite tricky in away
so when I first started off econometrics
this this variable s it's something that
could be called a bad control is
something that is caused by what the the
on-site messaging the thing you're
interested in and effects why and that's
something that's hard to get my head
around until I found the cause of the
framework done by people like judea
pearl it's helped me to augment my
approach to to causal inference so in
that case we can have everything in the
model we can model the direct effect of
mly controlling for s and G and there
there are some statistical concepts
behind that I went already going to that
in too much detail because it can go on
for quite a while and get confusing but
you might thought well there's a bit
more to it that was our first diagram
there must be something else going on
and you're right and it's the fact that
these messages that by being targeted
they they have trigger behaviors so we
now introduce this other variable called
T for triggers and now we have two
different
is going in so someone there there's
trigger behavior on the website so if
someone hasn't been active for the last
say for the first 60 or for a 60-second
period then we will choose to display a
message as a way of trying to encourage
them to sue convert go to the booking
engine so with this we're targeting
people that are really less likely to
convert so between T and why there is
this negative effect and then the other
case going from someone who's done a
trigger or there's been let's add the
trigger they all get the message so
there is that strong direct positive
arrow going in there and now adding that
into the model we have another path and
that's mty and of this it's like a
classic confound the case it is a common
cause of the very interest in modeling
em and the target why so we need to
control for this variable it'll help us
to have more precise estimates of the
direct effect and and one thing that
that can can happen is you could have in
this case it might be you do a
correlation between m and Y and it could
be negative and that could come about
because of having this emitted variable
bias if you didn't include that in the
model you'd have your your linear
regression say there's negative effect
but why could that be it could be the
the average conversion rate on website
is 5% someone who who has the trigger
behavior their conversion rate might be
3% and then of the people that see that
trigger and get a message 4% of them
could convert so that's lower than the
average on the website but that's an
uplift to say 30% on people that have
received that trigger so that now
becomes the positive effect as opposed
to a negative one and yes so one way we
can do this and we do this
is quite a lot is a be testing so it's
something you can do quite well if you
have the scale of data so yeah you have
stuff like minimum detector effect and
there's a lot of literature on there
with unless you have a high scale of
data you're not in the position to do
validate B tests so if for most people
doing modeling of causal diagram can
help them to estimate the direct effect
with reasonable validity if a/b testing
isn't available to them and before I've
done stuff on white board as a way of
trying to get my idea around a space how
do these different variables affect each
other and there's tooling that can help
you to to do this once you have very
complex models with dozens of variables
hundreds of variables and this is
something that you'd see a lot in in
product websites likes a tuber all those
kinds of big big startups they they will
have so many things that they can feed
into their model but to do causal
inference they need an effective way to
automate it to make it quite reliable
and yeah this is an example that's all I
found online called bagga-t so you can
it's you can add variables on in a web
browser and map out a different
relationship so as you've seen here it's
a tutor estimate the direct effect you
can you have to control the on G s and T
and that that was what we had said
before from going through these backdoor
paths and you can see Diagnostics on on
these variables so things like this is
the causal path or here's a biasing path
and then there are many Python packages
now that enable you should do this kind
of stuff so causality calls the
graphical models do why and then as a
quick refresher on this if we wanted to
do to estimate the effect of someone
clicking through on a Google ad on
conversion rate you have the confounders
before of M&S but you do not need to
control 40
t towards the end here is a Collider ver
oh no sorry s is a Collider we have to
block that as before but T here is s is
applied oh this was going on about s
later on yes we don't need to control
control for T here it's blocked by s
they block by I'm sorry
we've controlled your controlled for s
and n on their other paths but in this
final part the longest path of GS mty
we've conditioned on the controlled for
s so that was a kind of before and now
we need to think in this part of the
grayed out s how do we then block this
path this final path and we can block it
with M so these three piles really need
to control for two variables m and s you
can also add in T if you're interested
in seeing the effect of that but it's
not it's not something you need in in
this model and so in summary that calls
the diagrams they're great because you
can map out all your knowledge of a
domain space and make your assumptions
explicit which is something very tricky
to do sometimes in such large models
it's a toolkit for applying identifying
the minimum number of control variables
you need so in that last one
you don't need to control for the
triggers of messages and you can iterate
your diagrams quite a lot and that's
that's always nice to have if you have
two stakeholders you say oh like this
this is something else that you consider
in the model and then the final section
here is just an overview of the types of
biases that that we'd seen before so if
if we look at it as x y&z on which is
just three variables and methane it out
we've got our pens and we can map out
these things for this variable Zed and
then we've got x and y we can add some
arrows in and see well for this first
case you have the confounding variable
and through all these diagrams we're
going to
the direct effect of X on Y in purple
and then you have the bottom the
backdoor path and for here the
confounding variable is when Z is a
common cause of x and y and for that you
you need to control for these types of
variables so in the corner there you
might see you have x and y and you've
got the arrows going out from from Zed
and with these ones you want to control
for confounders they will help your
models estimates they'll increase the
precision precision of estimates that
helps reduce the bias and then colliding
variables you have it the other way
around you have Z being a common effect
of of x and y and controlling phase
would introduce a direct path between x
and y that is not there and that is
something if you control for it it will
bias your estimates so they
automatically block backdoor piles you
don't need to control for them but there
are cases as before that s where you
could have a variable that's a
confounder on one path and they collide
or another and that was the main thing
that was confusing for me when I was
doing causal inference on big datasets
and then the final case here is
mediating variables so you'd have X call
Zed and then Zev calls Y these orange
arrows is the indirect effect of X on Y
but you might only care about the blue
arrow X or Y so mediators they introduce
this indirect effect of x and y and if
you only care about the total effect of
x and y that you don't need to control
for em and that they're like another
kind of way of spicing out causal models
so in summary causal questions are
ubiquitous we've seen an example from
today in the news where there is this
kind of confusion around Association
versus causality and causal effects can
be estimated without randomized
experiments fortunately for us it's
something that's taken oh it's only the
last 20 years so where we've had that
kind of knowledge in in stats community
kind of outline to everyone the calls
the diagram is useful for modeling you
can you can iterate with it you can
involve other people in the business to
map out other variables that affect what
you're trying to arrest to mate in types
of biases control for confounders and
beware of colliders that that's
something that troubled me of the collar
metrics these things called bad
variables like controls and then there's
tooling out there now that can help you
to choose your control variables for
scaling out to large data sets I mean if
you want to look at further resources
Judea poles because why is is a great
one it was quite quite a read for me
when I was first picking out because I
came in with knowledge of the collar
metrics and that confused things for me
a bit and then introduction to applied
econometrics and gracious tanishka
mastering metrics
Pishko was my professor at the LSE and
he was great explaining things in the
basic ways if you have stats and maths
knowledge at a university level then
it's something that could be a good read
for you and then Python libraries you're
going to do linear models and stats
models the main one linear models is
another good one for econometrics and
then my packaged apple pie can help out
with encoding variables Diagnostics it's
like a fun thing for me
[Applause]
yeah thank you for the dog I guess sure
yet - how many - how many variables do
you think this kind of approach is
scalable is it like is there an upper
limit um to my knowledge is not really
an upper limit if you look at other
companies like uber as I say for uber
eats or Airbnb they often have causal
inference teams that you harness all
their all their big data hundreds of
variables from from different products
and things like that and they have these
things called causal engines where they
they can pipe in all these different
things and yeah so look at that dag and
then think okay while running this on
whatever scale these are the things to
control for they they had that figured
out so it's my knowledge there isn't
like an upper limit to this
one last question perhaps
I am wondering if you go with the
traditional Georgia
how different result
so you talking about things like model
specifications so if you changed an
arrow in a different direction say yes
my feature importance I think you're
talking more about machine learning
algorithms so if he did linear
regression in in SK learn or random
forest and you saw that what the would
there be different seasons competitor
doing and the calls away so in summary I
think that you could have different
effects if you just threw everything in
in the model all the variables and then
feature importance it might if two
variables are strongly correlated but
one of them you shouldn't control fall
by the calls of diagram it would then
have the impact of making your estimates
more biased there's less precision
because you start to get more clarity in
the model and that can increase your
standard errors that kind of thing if
you're doing a basic linear model see a
feature importance it's it calculates a
bit more differently and machine
learning compared to what you do with
them P values on F test on the basic
linear models so I mean they would leak
some similarity you'd expect doing
linear regression in SK learn and doing
it in stats models but yeah it's it's
all kind of dependent really on what you
include in your model
[Applause]